this girl went viral because she wanted
the baby shower gift back after her
friend had a miscarriage
and I want to know your thoughts would
we are we capable
can you pull that up
I mean if you it's like you're just
gonna keep like an empty cradle at your
house like right like it's like I might
as well get my money back yeah yeah yeah
you're doing something yeah it's like I
don't want to be reminded of this every
second
I know
so you don't think that she's
necessarily wrong how did she ask for it
give it back the first look it's so as
we know you have some extra time now
okay it's certainly a tricky situation
there's no doubt about that okay it's a
400 baby shower gift after a miscarriage
and the 400 do they say what it was
okay
um last week a woman on Reddit sparked a
debate after starting a thread the user
began by explaining that the woman she
gave the gift to is a long-term family
friend of her husbands and the baby
shower registry as a gift around
uh
she's saying that both the man and the
woman are like they make over six
figures
who how did she ask not her not the not
the the recipient yeah the recipient her
and her husband
fell out
um I do think you kind of cannot the
Lord already took the gift back from her
right what I mean and the thing that
sucks is if you had a baby shower and
then a miscarriage that was a probably a
really late miscarriage yeah which is
very traumatizing it is really [__] up
or what if this woman knew she had a
history of miscarriages and she was like
I'm gonna have this baby shower early so
I get these presents interesting that's
the whole scandal
how did she ask for it she was doing
like a tick tock talking [__] or
something it's not she says it's not
something she can use for her older kid
um
okay so basically she's saying if it's
going to sit in the Box in her attic for
years
that's where we're getting stuck
oh my God it's just you know it's like
it's a gentle nudge like hey I think
some things in life you gotta take the
loss like once you spend the money you
gotta just know no matter what it's not
coming back yeah
but I get it it does really suck because
400 is a lot
yeah can you imagine
[Music]
ZocDoc is a free app you can find
amazing doctors and book appointments
online with thousands of top rated
patient review doctors and Specialists
go to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top rated doctor today that's
zocdoc.com trash zocdoc.com trash go to
drink simplyspiked.com trash Tuesday to
find out how to get your hands on new
simply spiked Peach that's drink
simplyspiked.com trash Tuesday flavored
beer naturally flavored with other
natural flavors simply spiked Co
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked as a trademark
of the Simply Orange Juice company order
your THC products from mood today for 20
off your first order and free gummies go
to hellomood.com and use promo code
trash Tuesday that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20 off your order and free gummies hey
sluggies and happy birthday America what
a fun episode we have today I'm so
excited to tell you I am still on the
road I love coming and Performing for
you guys I'm getting my special ready so
my jokes are getting so good and I
cannot wait for you to see them you can
see me next in South Carolina in
Greenville July 28th and 29th I will be
in my hometown of Philadelphia August
11th and 12th come to that one it's
going to be wild bring me a Cheesesteak
I'm going to be in Calgary at the
outdoors Comedy Festival with Andrew
Schultz August 27th and in San Francisco
at Cobbs Comedy Club September 15th and
16th and Austin Texas October 6th and
7th there's also a bunch more dates
being added so go to annieleterman.com
shows and also every Thursday is my solo
podcast Annie wood where you can hear uh
updates on my life and other weird
little things all right guys I'll see
you later hi slugs I'm back on the road
doing stand up it's so much fun and this
month I will be in New York City I will
be at Joe's Pub July 19 through 23rd we
added a show on Sunday I can't wait to
see you guys guys there and in September
I'll be in DC and then Boston at the
Wilbur Theater and I'm also going to be
in Madison Wisconsin Detroit Chicago and
San Diego I cannot wait to see you guys
get tickets at Esther onice.com
I love you you're my best friend okay
bye
[Music]
welcome to the AI robot themed episode
that will blow your mind about how
futuristic we all are yeah we're looking
towards the future we're well your
nipples are I wanna sure well one is
looking to the past and one is to the
future I know I can't see
where they are now I think we got the
bit right I don't have to do it this
isn't exactly how I pictured sexy robots
but it's not the worst case I no the the
what I thought was gonna happen was they
were gonna like fashion like boxes
together and like you know there's like
those like what are those tubes for and
then you put them over there like what
they use for like installation too yeah
what our parents used to dress us up for
Halloween when they didn't want to buy
us a costume get cardboard boxes and
tell us what we are well my mom hand
sewed all of my costumes so I can't
really relate to that did you ever sew
you into Augustine does she ever sell
your skin into wait a second let me get
this straight the mom who neglected you
yeah well she was busy sewing it hand
sewed all of your Halloween costumes
that's correct yes your honor that is
correct
do you know what you know she had said
to you what do you wish that your mom
had done differently I I'm with you
because we all have like some [__] thank
you I know you'll no
um we know the story she was a she was a
perfect
a Martha
and from uh handmaid's tale and she was
no she she's a great mom I love her she
and she read to me so I know I oh God
just teach you to read
I know your parents withheld reading
from you no they were busy reading they
wouldn't allow you to read
um I think it's so cute that your mom is
like a legitimate writer and like you
kind of can't read I know it's twisted
it's twisted but she would always I
always liked I would go into her bed and
she would tell me the story of the book
that she was reading she would like tell
me the what was happening really wait
that sounds fun I loved that oh my God I
would love it was almost like TV it was
like oh okay I got like the TV version I
don't know that let's notes so that's so
soothing when anyone that you love like
explains something to you I've noticed
like since my dad is older if I go to a
restaurant with him and he's like all
confused like he's never been there
before
he loves it so much when I'm like okay
here's this on this section like the
pizzas are here you can get this like
people why are you taking him as a
Cheesecake Factory to be honest it's a
very overwhelming menu whatever it is
wait a second I want to get into this
yeah no I have a lot to say about
Cheesecake Factory so you just pause
right there well like I don't I'm not I
have no objections to their interior
design I think it's actually quite
impressive what they do like I you know
it's super I everything about it I don't
give a [__] about except for the fact
that like the menu is everywhere it's
it's there's too much there's two like
option paralysis
okay yes that's very that's like a very
basic first level complaint about
Cheesecake Factory and I understand that
we've all had it she's coming for you
but more importantly nothing is good
truly but the cheesecake that's my
biggest complaint I've enjoyed many of
things there I will say this because I
agree I actually very much agree with
both of you there was a almost there's
like a distinct line in my life before
and after learning that Cheesecake
Factory was not good but like up until
like 24 I thought it was the nicest
restaurant that you could ever go to I
thought every single meal was the best
version of it I loved all the choices
and then when I started dating Dave I
was like we were in my hometown I was
like we could go to The Cheesecake
Factory and he like
I think there's no like income bracket
or anything though it defies I think it
is like
just on the sheer options alone the fact
that one person can go get like an
angel-haired shrimp pasta and the other
one can get
nachos or what it's like this is well
now I'm like what's going on in that
kitchen it's all Frozen like
everything's disgusting and Frozen like
that's what I think like it's got to
just be like huge freezer space that's
okay so when I worked at Hard Rock Cafe
for two months before they opened and
got fired before
um did you want to clarify that it
wasn't you like it wasn't the guest came
in and went we got it exactly but
pre-guest so like we can't I was fired
but they freaking like read big
restaurants like that they they use
microwaves it's frozen like it is so
it's [__] it's that's like that
almost broke my heart more than like
learning stuff on the side of the high
volume of the restaurant think about how
impossible that would be to be having
fresh
Cheesecake Factory I'm not I think that
um it's just every time a Filipino
Auntie comes to America for the first
time it's always like let's go to The
Cheesecake Factory because the
perception or like the image of it on
the other side of the world is like as
as bougie as it gets right like before I
came here I used to think Kenny Rogers
Roasters was like the bougiest thing I
could go to TGIF I've never even heard
of that place is that where you go and
people are just me do Tony hedgecliffe
brings you like a Kenny Rogers Kenny
Rogers ahead restaurant the restaurant
chain in the Philippines and it killed
really yeah it was like a line outside
it was such a big deal when it opened
like we flew to a different city just to
try it did your dad look like Kenny
Rogers a little bit with a white hair
yeah wait do you have a beard you're
done um he could have sometimes he did
when he was depressed he'd grow on did
you have a restaurant where people were
mean to because we had that in Chicago
it was the we oh we had I never went to
it at debevics and that was like the
most we of course I loved it yeah like
that was my most fun maybe that was like
my comedic origin story was going to add
to bevix and getting a 10 negative
attention and it is true like you're
paying to get it yeah like what else can
I possibly do I wonder like does it get
sexual like do some customers like pull
their waitress aside and they're like
tell me how small my dick is yeah spit
on my face wait what is that though like
I would never go to a place like that
I'd be terrified I'd go home so sad and
cry because it's like fun and it's
something to do I don't know like it's
just the most likes being made fun of
that than anyone on Earth and also in
the midwest when you're like a teenager
there's nothing to do I don't know like
yeah someone's gonna be mean to me well
I always wanted to work at one of those
places me too but I never wanted to be a
customer around I was like I know we
experienced enough you know we weren't
going to recreate our trauma at a
restaurant when there's food involved
let's just say I like to dish it out as
your waitress
can we if we ever have a sleepover have
like a little role play moment where you
we don't know your awareness that it
might not happen now is actually
comforting you need to hear that the
Hope has hurt me and Kyla are on a
pretend date and you're our server and
you're mean to us oh we're doing this
yeah let's go right now okay I'm gonna
send how many scenarios are we having at
this leap how many costumes
we could be anywhere are we going to
your parents house I don't even [__]
float that out there because a sleepover
at my parents house in my parents
basement with you two
I mean if you guys really want this show
to be successful like that will
spiritual things will happen your mom
will be like folding her clothes wait
there is something really like what my
favorite room in your home even though
all the rooms are like the interior
design is incredible by the way it's
like perfect mid-century
um but my favorite room in your house is
your actual bed it's so comforting that
all of your laundry is just like piled
on top and you just sleep underneath it
the one room where we have to keep the
door closed Dave doesn't let people I
don't acknowledge that room as your
bedroom because I when I was the closest
with you that couch was your bedroom no
I know I was gonna say you know that
that's technically Dave's bedroom Dave's
full that's his full those clothes are
just Esther pretending to be next to him
she just stuffed to look like a person
was there so that's sort of a um not a
red flag but something that kind of
gives me pause like if I date a guy and
I go to his home and everything is in
its perfect place I feel feels so
uncomfortable so when I go into
someone's home and things are messy and
I can squat on the floor and I don't
really need to give a [__] and I open
their fridge and shits everywhere
there's comfort in that for me a million
percent yes of course you don't want to
go in and be like in trouble it's almost
like with the Aesop like products
perfectly lined up in their bathroom
like that is very American Psycho and
like this guy is gonna make my life like
he's gonna complain about every sloppy
thing that I do yeah why are you worried
about where the Dana is in your house
yes you guys are not invited to my house
is it really clean yeah always the one
that keeps it clean
yeah
I don't you know I there's no blood or
anything that I tried yeah no but like
are you like
like how do you relax at home like I
think because I work a lot at home if
everything is a mess I can't focus you
know I just found out from my Academy
and Coach I don't want to call this lady
but um she was like I don't know who
this woman is she wandered off the
street I said okay yes you're in charge
um I would take the drugs but she said
that
um because I'm really working on like
calming my central nervous system she
said that you being in clutter leaves
you in a state of fight or flight which
makes so much sense but I am too
paralyzed to fix it well no there's a
difference between living in a certain
amount of clutter like I have like I do
clean my room once a week my sheets are
changed every week every week I cannot
go with my sheets aren't you serious
yeah because I don't like that I don't
like being dirty like I have a
heightening clean clean then right now
so I can be messy but I'm really clean
right like my bathroom my toilet is
scrubbed once a week like there has to
be some type of
I pay someone to do it because I when I
see how they clean after my cleaning
lady comes over and she cleans like the
level of clean she doesn't like it's
just not a possibility for me like the
the list of things it just wouldn't
happen so I just it's like but she does
scrub scrub up but I think fancy is
right clean versus messy very two very
different but I have okay I struggle
with both because I mean obviously could
just be like messy and have some like
clothes on the floor that you could wear
again that aren't like that like dirty
or whatever and then you can have like
you know a tuna can that's open that's
sitting there and things are crawling in
and out oh yeah it's a big No-No food uh
food in my bedroom not allowed I know my
friend roomie came over recently and she
was like well okay one thing to start is
no fish wife in the bedroom
okay that was polite I'm actually
surprised you didn't like do a full
clean before she came over because she's
so pretty she came over when my mom was
in town and my mom was mid doing that so
you thought it would be good enough but
she hadn't quite well also it's like I
can't I am what I am like it's just it's
a mess I'm messy especially in that
bedroom it's not in good condition right
well don't you think that like we have
in common that our moms like did
everything for us yeah and it is like
I'm not mad my mom for that obviously
but it died
it just makes it makes it a very painful
thing
like it's not in our bodies and so it's
just harder and it does us a disservice
it was like kalila was like you know
beaten into work yeah and so now look at
her she's a clean toilet every week but
I do have a question you have to put
rocks all down while you're able to
clean the toilet
I feel like whip myself like everything
[Laughter]
miracle
sure wait I have a question what a Tin
Fish
makes you think Hmm I should eat this in
bed well I think it's actually perfectly
packaged for a bed snack myself is it a
bed snack is Tin Fish a bed snack I have
a good excuse I I think let me know but
it was like a travel snack and so I was
packing it it was you know it was in
transition it wasn't it doesn't belong
there but it did stay there longer than
it like I didn't put it away in the
kitchen which I should have done
um I went home with a guy once in New
York he was like a friend of a friend
and I had a crush him he was fat he was
like a fat ugly guy but he was very
funny which was like my type because
it's kind of like the Captain Save a
hose like I had that like where I was
like oh I see that he's like hot but no
one else does I love that we all have
this issue yeah I was like I'll you know
I'm gonna be like the hottest girl I've
ever had or whatever
exactly yeah I'm like he's not gonna be
mean to me he's not gonna talk [__] on
me my whole thing is when I [__] my
when I lost my virginity to my boyfriend
in high school when I was 14. he told
everyone I was like bad and bad like it
was a water bed he told everyone that I
felt like a dead fish like a fish wife
and
um which was just like I mean I'm
swimming sir sorry I'm 14. but it was so
like I was so then every time I like
hooked up with someone I was so afraid
they were gonna like spread rumors about
me or whatever that's very trauma so but
whatever he ended up in jail
because I framed him
no but um but I went home with this guy
and I was like you know he's just a
little rougher on the edges I like a
chubby guy or whatever
his place was and I'm a messy person it
was the most disgusting thing and the
fact that he didn't even try to clean it
and then he like wasn't that into me
like it was like so hurtful like the
whole I couldn't I remember he was
watching Tim and Eric I just like stayed
at his house and we watched him in Eric
for like
you know a full day or something and I
just like had just I just started liking
Tim and Eric again like three years ago
like he ruined Tim and Eric I was like
this guy was so mean to me I hate that
he'd be able to and Theo is cute though
if the person is nice but I
um to your point the people who have
been meanest to me have been ugly dudes
I've hooked up with there was this one
guy I slept with who was a friend of a
friend and I honestly thought I was
being so charitable because I'm like
there's no am I gonna write this off on
my taxes yeah like there's no way this
guy like I knew the last girl he hooked
up with and like I mean I was like
there's no way in hell he's gotten any
kind of [__] in the last like six years
of his life you know I got a little
tipsy he was really nice at first but
the amount of things he said about me
after he slept it also about my
appearance by the way yes I know like I
was way out of his League completely out
of his League to the point where my
friends were like are you sure you want
to do this yeah and I did and he was
like oh yeah like her ass wasn't fat
enough for me like so many companies
like he's got really disgusting traps
it's like they're really chubby big trap
she needs a little Botox on those traps
but like mean [__] and I was like wait a
second nice
said this his name was just bleep that
out but I couldn't believe it and so
I think I think they're meaner or they
feel they sense our arrogance and that
pisses them off like they sense that
we're coming in like I could do whatever
it's like and then they're like I'm
gonna show this [__] because they do
show us well you I think he's
anticipating me saying yeah I went
slumming you think that's right that's
funny I think it's funny it's like Curb
Your Enthusiasm as I'm funny when you go
like cocky into a situation and the guy
just completely has no interest in you
it happens to me all the time it's like
whenever I'm like let me see I got this
let me spin this for you guys in a way
that you'll like I think what I re and I
really think this is that these men are
so insecure and have such low self-worth
that they know that you are so shiny and
special and beautiful that they know oh
I can't have this girl like I had her
for I had a taste I can't have her
permanently so they they they have to
dig at you because they have low
self-worth well what if they say we're
[__] for coming in all again thinking
that they are fat
also I would have slept with him
multiple times like it could have been a
thing if I hadn't heard through the
grapevine no he said my ass wasn't fat
enough it's his insecurity about himself
was he broke is it healthy for us to
think this or not which one's the
healthiest way and I also don't think
you went in there cocky it's not like
you're like let me [__] you you ugly pig
you might have liked that actually you
were probably really no I actually
really liked him and was like oh my God
I'm gonna date this guy yeah
ever been on the hunt for a new doctor
and you ask literally everyone you know
for recommendation and you go to that
doctor and it's still not a great
experience yeah because it's really hard
to find doctors that will actually
listen to you actually take time with
you and also impossible to find
Specialists that's why Sock Doc has
fixed my life and it's great too because
it's on an app you can find out if they
take your insurance you can get
appointments as soon as 24 hours I've
done it with a dentist I've done it with
a neurologist it's been unbelievable
ZocDoc is my favorite app ZocDoc is a
free app where you can find amazing
doctors and book appointments online
we're talking about booking appointments
with thousands of top-rated patient
review doctors and Specialists you can
filter specifically for ones who take
your insurance are located near you and
treat almost every condition you're
searching for these docs all have
verified reviews from actual real
patients not Bots and the average wait
time to see a doctor booked on ZocDoc is
between just 24 to 48 hours that's it
and you can even score some Same Day
appointment
no ZocDoc rules
I had a toothache at 11 p.m one night
and I had a dentist appointment the next
day that's amazing and the dentist was
so awesome and it was a beautiful it was
like such a good experience I love dogs
and once you find the dock you want you
can book them immediately like Annie
said with just a few app Taps no more
waiting awkwardly on hold with a
receptionist go to zocdoc.com trash and
download the ZocDoc app for free then
find and book a top-rated doctor today
that's
zocdoc.com
trash Z that zocdoc.com trash
zocdoc.com trash summer's coming up and
life is infinitely more exciting when
there are peaches involved wouldn't you
say Annie oh listen I like them I like
to eat them I like to to chop them up I
like to get them in my DMs I like to
suck on a peach and you guys that's why
we're brought to you by simply spiked
Peach from the makers of Simply Spike
lemonade simply Spike Peach is now
available 21 and over only and it
contains alcohol I don't drink but I I
do notice the alcohol that is at
people's barbecues that I go to and it's
so boring so that's why I always bring
simply spiked Peach I'm like look Auntie
Anne is here to throw down wait but
Annie do you know that they have the
peach mango this is it right here in my
hand that's different peaches it's like
the best and you guys it's so refreshing
um all of all flavors of Simply spiked
are crafted with five percent ABV and
five percent real fruit juice squeeze
then concentrated and this spring simply
spiked has introduced a new flavor that
fans have been asking for since day one
simply spiked Peach pick up a variety
pack today to try all four new fresh
flavors their signature Peach strawberry
peach kiwi Peach and mango peach and
simply spiked Peach is the newest
addition to the simply spiked family
joining simply spiked lemonade which
broke the internet when it dropped last
summer with its four bold and refreshing
refreshing flavors the lemonade
strawberry lemonade blueberry lemonade
and watermelon lemonade
it's so good really let me smell it it
really is so good you guys go to
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday to
find out how to get your hands on new
simply spiked Peach that's drink simply
spiked.com trash Tuesday
it smells so good it really smells good
oh flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply spiked cold
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked as a trademark
of the Simply Orange Juice company
what are your thoughts on financial
slavery explain
um there are men out there in real
relationships like married who find
women either like not necessarily even
cam girls they find these relationships
on the internet where a woman
um financially enslaves them and they
like the feeling of being like held like
like the threat of being like I gotta
give it all to her and secrecy because
the hot wife I have kids I have all of
these things
and they're like just addicted to the
feeling of being dominated financially
well yeah that makes sense like I get it
from like a submissive I always think
that too like when I spend money on
someone it's kind of submissive of me
it's like oh you can have it like so I
kind of understand the angle there but
that is
I mean that's cool for those girls
that's cool all right for the wife and
kids I think okay so I think I've had
boyfriends so I've never dated someone
who's like super rich and I've dated
guys that like have a lot of money but
they're not very generous okay that's a
that's a thing yeah we're like that's
weird dude I I dated a guy who was uh 15
years my senior they're always older so
twelve thousand dollars a day I remember
because I was his assistant then we
opened the shop together and flirty
little [__] came into work like hi Papa
it's a shop girl and
um he couldn't even spring like sixty
dollars a night for a Travelodge when we
would travel like for work together yeah
he would make me sleep in the back of a
[__] kitchen a restaurant his friend
Owen and I was like like one of those
Crisco boxes around he made me shower at
a 24-hour fitness because the place
didn't have hot water and so like he was
that [__] but cheap he paid for
himself to have a nice place no we would
like sleep you know and I'm just like my
Eczema is flaring the Travelodge he
didn't want to like
he would feel like I was like taking
advantage of him or something and I'm
like you just I'm like I have no money
you have tons of this was when I was
like so broke and I was dating this guy
and he got in a fight with me over I had
um accidentally left my credit card at
home and we were going to do a we were
shopping for him for a thing that he
wanted to do
so I went shopping with him right it was
there was nothing I was getting out of
this except I was just helping him you
know I was just getting like people
pleaser I hate that points and you might
know the story and then and I was like
oh I left my credit card my debit card
at my house can you get my parking
uh-huh not like we're valeting like can
you get my like a dollar for two hours
parking
he was like this is a I'm never spending
another I mean I was literally there
doing something for him and I was so mad
I was like just what the but it was more
of like the power thing like he was like
you can't take my mind I'm like what
like when we go out to eat when I'm
helping you if I'm working with
something on you all day with you on
something all day and then we go out to
eat like you aren't paying like buy my
meal
by Miami yes I helped you I was like
your unpaid intern all day basically buy
my meal side note I would let donut
financially enslave me like I want to be
dominated by Donuts that's not a good
that means she's got some expensive
bills I just paid this past week four
thousand dollars for Diagnostics and
there is no diagnosis for my dog what
like so there's owning a pet is
financial slavery in California in the
United States yeah it's like every tiny
thing if you choose to have a dog
unless you know what I mean like you
just I just I want her to die I want her
to own my ass she does she does okay but
like I wanted to like you wanted to
drive you around kind of I wanted to
piss on my face like that can easily be
we could do that I can put a little
brass in her mouth I understand a little
grass patch that's great should they
have that in your mouth like this when
men like want like a woman to dominate
them like I understand it do you do the
thing Whitney does wear the whole face
you open your mouth and her whole head
goes in your mouth no no yeah Whitney
really like tongues I know she did that
to one of my foster puppies and I was
like oh that one's got worms yeah that
one's got worms careful she's like I
don't care do you guys I need to ask you
this do you think I think about this all
the time do you think our dogs really
love us or are we just like their source
of food and safety I think Randy loves
me he freaks out when I come home from
the airport he like and he misses me
when I'm gone
you don't do anything for him you guys
are brothers
you guys are little siblings Todd's
children Todd has all these frogs and
[__] now it's so annoying Todd just more
attention to us frogs is the best like
storyline ever that's literally all
anyone is now it's like a Terraria talk
wait Kyla do you think your dogs
actually love you or is it just like
your food you do can you tell me why
um
they just do Esther it's very cool there
there's something's wrong with you I
just I want to know that she's not a
little like slave like she's we are
we've captured them why is it at that
after I feed my dogs and they've gotten
everything they need for me do they
still want to be like pushed up against
me and be close and show me like
affection okay when their stomachs are
full and they need nothing else for me
they still want to be close to me okay I
just can't believe it Randy's just so
cute I can't believe him the love is I
know it like I wanted this staring at
her all day
something is really going everything
looks like him everything I say look I'm
like Randy Right Now esther so insulting
do you guys um um watch any Shira
um videos sprinkle sprinkle yes
um I saw this clip of her she's this
woman who gives basically like life
dating like advice she's incredible and
she's so no [__] but she basically
she was talking about like ratchet foods
you shouldn't order on a date or is it
on a first date
no I saw this clip and I literally was
like I knew what the first one was gonna
be because it was something that my
sister orders and I'm like please don't
let it be what my sister gets and it was
fettuccine alfredo
it was the first on her list do not
order this on a date it's a ratchet food
I forgot the other ones though that is
like a because when you eat fettuccine
alfredo like splatters too it's like not
like a hot thing to eat in front of
someone on a first date I don't even
know why but instinctually I knew it was
going to be that and I still I don't
have an explanation why I think it's
because it's a very like basic
introductory type of pasta that's on
every menu in existence like even Mall
food oh well one time yeah Dave and I
took my sister to an Italian restaurant
that was pretty nice they didn't have it
on the menu and she asked if they could
make it for her and they did
and that experience just lingering in my
life I knew that was going to be on
there could have taken to the Cheesecake
Factory she loves Cheesecake Factory
guys I was looking at my phone earlier I
wanted to explain to you why I got a
comment I did um Josh powder's podcast
and someone wrote a comment on it this
was like four weeks ago and they said I
went to a Halloween party at the College
of Santa Fe and I swear Annie was there
it was like 20 years ago I um I was
dressed like a [__] robot with a dryer
tube for my wang I don't okay
and this dude said hey you got to meet
my friend and he introduced me to a girl
that had star-shaped tin foil nipple
pasties he tried to get us to hang out
because we kind of matched maybe I'm
wrong but I'm keeping the dream alive
and I'm like oh no that's me
just paste these I don't remember these
things and then well it was a they said
it was a robot party and I was like I
don't have a robot costume so I just
didn't I was called flashing Annie in
college I was always flashing my boobs
so I just went topless and just had
pasties super cute I love that a YouTube
commenter found you they found it I feel
like you guys need to uh no rekindle no
oh God there's your next Julie
commercial
wait let's go back to ratchet Foods yeah
because what I want to know like what
other foods do you guys think would be
ratchet to order on a first date
one time I went out with my manager my
old manager and I ordered a lobster okay
that's I feel like that's and cracking
open a lobster in front of someone it
was just us and I was like and I just
like got in this big deal and I was like
and he was paying for it so I was like
you know and it was it really was pretty
decent Lobster is incredible because
they never even put the price if it's a
fancy place they put MP but you look
like trash here's the thing it's like a
high class immediately to trash I mean
there's just stuff all over your face
you're like sucking the um little legs
and stuff I wanted to read you guys
something that um what other foods do
you think
now I literally can't think like I don't
know but I think like if you go to like
a Thai restaurant it's like it's not bad
but you're just like that you're not
you're not exciting you're not showing
that you have like World experience or
that you're willing to try things or
like you're only ordering the pad thai
and then the Satay yes like just the
skewers and then that's it yeah you
gotta try it on my order oh my God I
tell you guys what fancy ordered at
McDonald's drive through
like when we all went to order as a
family
you guys Bobby already grilled me for
this I mean a burger but no tomatoes no
lettuce no nothing just the bread and
the meat and nothing else
and it's the longest order because it's
like it's because it's too dirty if the
other things are on it no I just I'm
picky I mean not just picky you guys
like he eats two things and two things
only right that is that's scary what do
you get from McDonald's
probably a quarter pounder with cheese
or
um you know a bigger nugget like not a
Happy Meal size but six to eight to
twenty I've not not gotten a 20 piece
definitely extra sweet and sour sauce
um fries obviously fries and sweet and
sour sauce yes yes they used to give
honey they used a little honey and I
like to dip the fries in honey that was
my thing when I was a kid I I hear you
on that but for me the sweet and sour
sauce is like it's my whole Spirit
that's I think
I've had it but I don't like the tartar
sauce it's fine but yeah sweet and sour
sauce feels ratchet to me that's sort of
this restaurant that was fake completely
fake it's a very high-end fake
restaurant that's a journalists created
and they did exactly what you guys were
describing he created this hype took
pictures of great food and then he was
just microwaving whatever you go to the
supermarket but people because the
experience and everybody gave a great
reviews and thought the experience was
great so that you know kind of like he
did it to demystify a little bit this
the culture that is that is here but
also this is what Bobby and I argue
about all day long like so he's a guy
who cares about like reputation Ambiance
like the whole experience like I go into
places like I don't care if they serve
my food with a [__] like rat on top
of it like if the food is [__] good
it's good I don't care parking with [__]
I don't care if the service was bad like
I objectively just want to try the food
so when I see Yelp reviews which is like
a super like chewy thing but like I
never trust like how many stars that's
like three and a half Stars I think is
The Sweet Spot we said yeah for certain
places because it's like people are like
just tell me if the food is good or not
tastes good I don't yeah I'm out I want
good too but they did this with Payless
didn't they really yeah they had
um this um fake new like branded shoe
that that was hype over weeks and weeks
and weeks and they did like a pop-up and
these shoes were like 500 but really
they were just all Payless shoes and
everyone was like these are extra
comfortable and I really feel the
quality of these shoes but they were
twenty dollars by the way Payless is
actually really expensive for what it is
it used to be much cheaper though pay
less likes I was always like this it
kind of reminds me of like IHOP where
you're like why are you you're competing
with Denny's right now like Denny's is
like giving you everything okay I feel
like they're about Target it's like I
think it's a Target I mean everything is
expensive because of inflation right now
but I definitely feel like Target is not
cheap Target's never been cheap Target's
expensive at least I think so the
furniture everything there is expensive
to me
I like
I'm so afraid of like being tricked in
that way because I will go to a
restaurant and I will like the problem
is that any bread any cheese is good so
like when I'm in a nice restaurant and
I'm just loving their bread and cheese
you're afraid it's like Wonder Bread
well I'm just like how big of a deal is
this really it's [__] bread like
anyone can do like I don't know I just
think
that's why I like when a restaurant does
a vegetable or a salad really good
because I'm like that is impressive to
me but if you're like making the world's
best grilled cheese like anyone can make
that it's just bread and cheese it's
amazing I like any food that's good but
if if you give me something overcooked
like it's gonna just be like I want my
money back like I really like an
overcooked like salmon or an overcooked
steak it's like it's not edible how do
you get salmon wrong is my question it's
so it's like it's quick guys like it's a
quick cook like when I when it's liking
it like I'm like oh it's like dry it's
I'm just it's unacceptable um
is it a place like we make the best
burger I'm like
Burger King is so [__] good like how
is it that much better than Burger King
I could just go to Burger King are you
still matching what what I'm sorry go
ahead you are you still going to Monty's
no I no I'm I'm way over vegan yeah I
have a confession that might like really
upset you but I've actually never had
Burger King Burger
really like in my life you would love a
Whopper Junior really yeah I've never
had a Whopper in my life guys I like in
and out I'm sick of people not liking it
I love in and out excuse I don't know
what I'm talking about you but I mean
it's just like other people don't know I
want name names but those are just the
naysayers who just kind of want to knock
you out and I like those [__] weird
shitty little flash fried potato like
the fries are like so like they sliced a
potato and just made fries out of them
it's just everything tastes good as hell
he's great there yeah and I believe that
the Whopper is delicious in fact like I
haven't had a shitty fast food burger or
a fast food item like everything is good
yeah that's why
I understand how that guy got away with
like scamming people because food if
it's like fat and salt it tastes good it
doesn't have to be anything special
um on the uh who is America the Sasha
show that I worked on back in the day
um we did one prank where
they we told Sasha dressed up like a
chef and he told
um this food critic that the food that
he was eating was like a dead person
that it was a person and that the family
had like
donated the body and the and the guy was
like savoring it he was like um
it was really so dark really funny that
is so dark I came across this post
um on Instagram I don't know how real
this is but it seems like a Reddit post
and it says how do I stop my husband
from going Goblin mode during sex my
husband says Goblin mode activated
when we start my husband says Goblin
mode activated when we start having sex
he growls and acts like a caveman and
then says Goblin mode off when we stop
and then pretends to not know what I'm
talking about when I ask him about it
that is absolutely unacceptable it's not
okay have you had a partner go in and
out of character like without your
permission [__] no have you
no have you I feel like you have come on
we know it's like you bang actor these
are actors this is what it is it's like
theater it's like theater Majors that
didn't pursue their dreams and then they
got to get it out somewhere and they're
like oh my God I guess I'm this is a one
girl show because I'm the only one in
the audience wait what is Goblin mode
like what does he do you think I it
sounds like just puts on a voice that's
so unhot well or is he like you know
gobbling is he just growling
it's at least Goblin mode sounds like
you're excited and energized and you're
gonna be going down there for a while
okay so I I do there's two things I
think here one is the guys that's so
annoying because it's like unhot what
he's doing but also if you love him and
you married him it's like can't you just
like
try to no because Todd does annoying
things not during sex but like Todd will
like he'll start like saying a thing
that he saw on a meme over and over
again and when I start to get annoyed
wait like I'll be like there was like
this video about this kid that like he's
like I love chicken so then Todd will
just start saying checking and it's like
okay sex no no no
this can relate this can relate you know
where it's like I know what you mean
right I don't know and I want to be like
I hate you like I want to be like I hate
please stop doing this and it's annoying
and then when I just leaned into it it's
like he never annoys me now like I just
like oh I love him and he wants to say
chicken and he can say chicken but could
you because there's something about sex
that I feel like because that I
understand that but sex like
it is there is a compatibility element
where like in that zone in that specific
act you kind of need to be on the same
page and it sounds like these two are
just so clearly incompatible they're in
different worlds but they're married so
there was a compatibility so I think
that it's like you do have control over
if you let go of your weird thing I
think you can I think you can think your
partner's hot even if they're doing God
movement but also I think this is what I
used to do uh when people if you kind of
overdo it to them like so if she came in
and was like Goblin mode back or
whatever he would probably be like you
know like of course the guy would be
like ew you're disgusting yes just do it
back to him until he stops that's really
good advice
I didn't write that okay like no one's
gone Goblin mode on me I think we don't
think they did oh now I want it no
nobody thinks that and just say it like
that dude you're like oh okay so I
recently posted the video of us from our
show a clip where we're talking about oh
choking in sex you thought I said
insects was I the only person you
weren't I in fact did I not make an
incest joke after that
I don't know it was lost I lost that one
but Dave literally goes oh you choking
insects and I was like okay wow thank
God
but so one of Dave's friends this writer
Steve Healy saw it and then he like Came
Upon This amazing like I think
culturally shifting concept or he
pointed out a flaw in our culture which
is that choking we call it choking
during sex but it's not choking it's
strangling strangulation like choking is
like there's something caught
but all of our culture calls this
choking and it's literally strangling so
we have to like correct that we have to
go back in time and edit and carry our
chat because here's the thing strangling
is scary it's like murdering your word
no I know but that's what it is yeah so
it's like sexual strangulation yes SS SS
SS Trooper but this is whoever invented
choking during sex is an idiot and used
the wrong word
yeah
so good one yeah good one not you
someone else's take that you brought to
the podcast good one Steve what's the
name Steve yeah is it is it Dave's
nightmare that his colleagues are
watching it yeah of course and then
commenting like hey I saw this
foreign
whether you're new to cannabis or an Old
Pro
are you guys Old Pros I am old yeah I am
a new Pro I think you are a new I am a
new Pro to cannabis I'm an x-pro there's
no denying that many of the products on
the market seem iffy at best and when
you want to relax iffy is the last way
you want to feel mood puts an end to
guessing games it's a hundred percent
federally legal Delta 8 and Delta 9 THC
you can have shipped straight to you no
doctors no waiting just Affordable Legal
THC for a limited time mood is giving
our listeners free Delta 9 gummies and
20 off your first order visit
hellomood.com and use our code trash
Tuesday so the experts at mood have
tested and tailored different strains
for specific moods they have energized
for when you're ready to seize the day
my favorite creative to get inspired and
just like mentally stimulated focused
which is perfect for getting into the
zone you already know which one mine is
right yours is erotic thank you and
maybe sleepy thank you or social so we
can finally get you to come out of your
house I also love body Soother like when
I'm sore at night like oh my God from
doing nothing yes from laying in my bed
[Laughter]
however you like to take THC mood has
you covered great for both beginner and
Veteran users or if you're somehow both
a beginner and a veteran like me ready
for a good time without the guesswork or
your THC products from mood today and
for 20 off your first order and free
gummies go to hellomood.com and use
promo code trash Tuesday that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20 off your first order that's
hellomood.com promo code trash Tuesday
for 20 off your order and free gummies
free gummies baby
are you uh are you a um person who
returns things after ordering from
Amazon do you repackage them print the
label and it's a pipe dream I get things
I'm always like I'll just order extra
I'll return it I order twice sometimes
I have two of like some really expensive
things and I just I can't they the
psychology of this like they know what
they're doing they know we're never
gonna return it it's so hard to return
things am I wrong I did it for the first
time this week I returned a headboard
um you got a headboard on Amazon I did
because it's for like a extra room that
I don't really care about and I got the
wrong size and I was so angry at myself
and I returned it I didn't pack it up
myself though and I didn't drop it off
myself I asked someone else too I just
printed the label I I printed the label
I sent it to their email and they
dropped it off for me
for jewels
returns are like that's probably the
biggest issue second to climate change
actually no bigger than climate change
similar too because of all the boxes
yeah yeah involved for our age group is
like us thinking that we'll be able to
do returns and then not I'm gonna run on
the platform
I want to ask you guys this question so
you remember how we had that episode
where the boot that I just bought had
two Nails sticking upward and it impaled
my foot yes and you still wore it as
some weird Filipino thing
yes you had to go to the bathroom and
jerk off
with you guys I they didn't give me
um they didn't allow a return because
they have an overall store policy of
like no returns which I didn't know
about I didn't know that stores did this
but apparently they're like no like you
can't I'm like no do you actually
impaled like you see these nails and she
touched them she was like Yep they're
there she's like I'm sorry like that's
just our store policy and I never been
mad or you guys I was like look at the
holes in my face oh that's not okay like
I have holes in my feet we have a
lawsuit here we have a lawsuit but they
said nothing and they were like here's
some store credit I'm like I and I don't
shop here regularly but here's what it
is this is what it is because in their
defense they're such a costume can I say
the brand you care I don't care it's
dolls kills they're it's all costumes so
it's like the a place where people must
wear it once and then return it all the
time yeah so I understand that but it's
no if there's yeah no [__] that and it
wasn't necessarily it wasn't exactly
cheap it was like two hundred dollars
yeah that's unacceptable no I would like
my money back if that's okay but it's
not her fault either it just is their
policy that I wasn't aware of they're
like we'll exchange it basically yeah
we'll give them yeah things are not the
way they used to be like I hate to sound
like an old person but I feel like when
you were young like quality Brands like
they don't there's nothing they don't
care about us somebody's been vintage
tea shopping
she's like it's all t-shirts They Don't
Care About Us I feel like Nordstrom used
to be able to return anything and now
they're kind of like they get kind of
nasty well your name's in the system yes
so we abuse Nordstrom's return policy
that's why I remember buying things from
other stores and knowing that I couldn't
return it back to them so I'd go to
Nordstrom's and Nordstroms would take it
even though it wasn't something I bought
at Nordstrom now they're strict it has
to have the little Nordstrom sticker on
yeah for good reason because I abused
them I use them for years I want to go
and instill one of those sticker pads
that'd be awesome I feel like they
it would have to be a no it'd have to be
a sticker that is associated with the
specific item I knew a girl from open
mics back in the day who and she's fine
now she's I think she's regular now but
she would she knew all the Urban
Outfitters like sale you know Urban
Outfitters would do like crazy sales
like things would be cut down like
you're like oh my God this is seven
dollars I spent you know
75 on it last week she like knew when
the sales were happening and stuff so
she would go to different places and
like buy them she had this whole hustle
of like buying and returning that was
like to the point where it's like that
can't like
if you break down down like per hour
what you're making it can't be that much
money for the amount of like different
locations and [__] but I was very guilty
of I would test drive especially when I
was first doing like Chelsea Lately and
all these like panel TV shows
um because I was making not that much
money and I was I was pretty broke I
would like fly out and basically make
I'd basically break even on what I was
making on the show for my flight and
then I have to get an outfit and I want
to look cute I'm on TV so I would like
get an outfit wear it and then return it
yeah I feel like that's fine I feel like
we all did that with our pets though I
did that for with that when I was on at
midnight I would order from revolve wear
it and return it oh my God I'm
definitely on a list with them a
revolving door we are revolve No I um
revolve is the one I've definitely like
made their money back for when you've
done that because I that revolve is
where I keep ordering two of these
expensive sweaters we're gonna all just
have to dress like twins a bunch not
because I'm like being codependent but
because I've literally ordered the same
thing so many times
so you're welcome revolve I like it
makes me so mad like I got fruit from
Whole Foods last week and the
raspberries you get them home they're
like there's mold in them when I was in
my 20s I had the energy to return fruit
at 35 like I just it's just a loss I'm
like I can't even afford to buy fruit
because so much of it is not good and
I'm not going I'm not going back in the
store and returning it even though I
should raspberries are a very delicate
fruit they go bad pretty quickly but to
get home it's like like also a stir I
mean not to like this isn't your fault
because but you have to be Asian about
the way you choose fruit I sit there and
I stare at fruit you ever see those old
Asian grandmas the way they look at
fruit the way they suss it out the way
they like bring it to the light they
feel it you have to you have to choose
it carefully no my my mom and dad are
both really good at that like I've seen
my dad just like pull out a chair at the
Costco blueberry session he's got
different glasses on like he's opening
and it almost like caused me anxiety
where then not sound like a jeweler yeah
my dad
is hip-hop has gotten Costco blueberries
I'm like I know these are going to be
the best [__] blueberries anyone
could ever find and then Dave is the
opposite I literally joke about this
like with my family privately it bind us
back in front of camera that Dave buys
his fruit like this
because she comes home with like the
nastiest most bruised like we whenever I
I'm like no bruises let's just start
there let's try that like he sucks at it
but don't strangle The Grapes before you
get them but now almost like how if I
was the child of like a famous like a
very talented like actor or something
like I get so much anxiety when it comes
to picking out fruit because I'm like I
could never follow in my appearance oh
yes I'll never be as good as them but I
used to think it was just a guy thing
that you guys just didn't know how to
choose fruit correctly but basically
like if because I I when I order like
instacart
and I look at someone's face like my the
person doing my shopping for me
immediately I know if I'm getting good
fruit or [__] fruit like if it's a guy
you look at their face like you're
looking at the fruit you're like
[Laughter]
it's true if it's an older person and
they have like a foreign name
um I'm like my fruit's gonna be
incredible if I have some 25 year old
like Scott my fruit is coming in Scotty
Scott with one tea is gonna [__] you up
you're not wrong dude in the pandemic
you guys know my friend John like he was
once going to it was like the first two
weeks of pandemic he was going to the
grocery store and I was like please all
I need get me garlic
he comes over
he has onions he's like here's your I'm
like you don't men don't know the
difference between garlic and onions
they're they're so how is that possible
can you imagine that I don't think we
can say all men because I think you have
to kind of like look at this and no but
you have to look at this the situation
because like would you rather get food
delivered from me or Todd
hmm
okay Todd is a man and I am a one would
you rather get food delivered and I
think you know the answer I think we all
know the answer okay who's gonna get you
the better food okay but I have an
argument against that because women we
do have literal better brains for
details or something about like we have
to keep the baby safe we have something
keep the baby cute
I actually think if you I 100 believe if
you were going to go pick out fruit I
think you could do a good job if it was
for an art project or something like if
someone was like yeah if it was for
something that wasn't I just don't if
you care I don't care about like I'm not
a chef I'm not like I eat like when I
remember
[Laughter]
this is what you did
that's how I feel I just shove I shove
and I would I would look if Todd was in
it if Pon was my instacart guy I would
put his picture to the light I'd be like
is he Asia where is he Hispanic I can't
tell but if there's like if I decide
that he's Asian I'd be like Oh I'm
getting good fruit yeah there's some
trust here but the name Todd is
definitely a red flag but it would not
be good no because Filipinos like to
name their um kids like the whitest
names ever Asians love white names no
his mom can't say Todd
we keep saying Todd and I was like we're
going to build an Empire
[Laughter]
mixing in on this Asian lifestyle here
I'm like selling so jealous I'm like I
just love his mom his crazy sister his
crazy aunts like it's so good I feel
that way too about Dave's parents where
I'm like oh I'm finally getting like
loving Jewish parents who are proud of
me who think I'm special who laugh when
I say your parents are obsessed with
their suckers that your dad is left to
everything you say they're like they
look down on me like I think they
they're excited that I have success but
they just look at me like this little
like Speck of dust you got that from
them
I feel like that's is it a [__] pile
feeling
to bring up episode one
oh my God
episode one cut to a clip
um oh my God but I I will say I'm
dedicated dedicating this summer to
committing to a lifestyle of fruit
I really want to pick out the zoo coming
out you're like I'm a fruit
I want to pick out good fruit I want to
be confident about it I want to have
amazing blueberries and strawberries I
want to be a berry house is this you're
saying you're having your dad come move
your house he's moving in Todd got a
bunch of
um fruit because he Todd's always like
I'm gonna go to the grocery store do you
want anything it's always when I'm on
the road or something and I'm like yeah
just something healthy
and so he gets for himself like Oreos
Doritos and then he gets me like grapes
bananas he got I was eating some grapes
that he got and they were so good today
and he was like I've never seen that
before I was like what he's like you
eating fruit like you're such a piece of
[__] I can't believe you live with
someone who eats Doritos and Oreos that
sounds honestly that sounds really
difficult but it's not but I want to
hold space for you no but can I tell you
it's so like kind of pathetic to watch
someone eat like that or just like this
is and he's just so young and he's 29 so
it's like I'm looking at him like this
is not and he's already like gets like
stomach but I'm like this is crazy
you're doing this remember when I was
smoking weed it was bad when I was
smoking weed it was I um Bobby stayed at
my place while I wasn't there and he
stayed at my place for like two weeks
and I came back and the whole cupboard
was chocolate I don't know if you know
what choco pie is but it's like an Asian
um like dessert but it's like every
single flavor matcha choco pie like the
boxes and boxes and boxes and under my
bathroom sink all like the cheapest like
ax products yeah oh and I'm like I
cannot believe well you know he didn't
bring girls over he had nothing to offer
them
but I just was like this the amount of
snacks that he was able to accumulate
like in two weeks I was shocked by well
I just you know I have somehow detached
that type of codependency like I've
gotten over that where it's like we have
to eat the same things so brave but it
took a long time I mean I've had
boyfriends where I'm like we can't eat
like this we can't eat like this but you
have have
so here's where it gets a little
difficult for me like one of the most
bonding things I can do with a partner
especially when we first meet is like
Bond over food like eating is such a joy
for me especially when someone eats just
likes the same stuff as me so that's
where it becomes a problem because we
have this thing that we love to do
together so even when the whole
conversation of like we can't keep doing
this we gotta start eating healthy like
it never happens and you just both
balloon together no but Todd has he has
restraint he stops he stops eating it's
so annoying is that like it's just so
annoying too because it's like it's like
all right are we gonna get fat together
oh no I'm gonna get fat next like dabble
in some snacks I'm actually relieved to
hear you guys say this because I always
joke like I'm like me and Dave have so
much in common we both love to eat like
we're so similar but like that is
something we Bond over and I'm always
like everyone [__] eats but also my
mom is like that where she can have like
three chips
how do people do that no it's like a
chip clip I've never owned a chip clip I
don't need a chip clip oh I buy the
clips they just never I've never I've
never needed a chip clip in my life
foreign
did you Lube them up for us aren't they
for Andres and say he did not Loop them
up for us that's definitely not what he
did he was cleaning them he probably did
clean them did you think they were dirty
fancy do you eat vegetables
sure which kind not potato is not it but
potatoes well look I went my my wife is
from the south and I went to a
restaurant of Spain not south of here
South Carolina oh is she yeah I didn't
know that is she Wyatt I always thought
she was Spanish well that would have
been a fun twist
and
we went to a restaurant we had a black
wife you didn't tell us about that it
means nothing guys everyone can marry
everyone obviously but it is fun when
someone brings their significant other
and they're not um
New York the Exotic one in this
situation and we went to a restaurant
where like all the veggies were feeling
like this mac and cheese
uh bacon wrapped
um asparagus so all of the you know
vegetarian section had all those yeah
okay I understand that that's like in
Illinois a salad bar has Jello what
that's not a salad like it has Jello
it's cow hooves isn't that what Jello is
what cow hooves oh yeah Jello is like a
hot girl food apologize I forgot wait
Andres I've heard that you
like basically like you CL you cook you
clean like you kind of do it all at home
is that true that's a rumor I heard
well we we divide the water okay but
yeah I do a lot of that
when she has a kid too she's got to do
that yeah she doesn't a lot of the kid
um
so no on the vegetables just unless
they're wrapped up in mac and cheese
look I I can do it it's not my favorite
thing
and fancy you need it I'm so sorry but
you need it in your diet we want you to
live long I I like Bobby's diet you know
but some people don't nicotine and
[__] Ash I'll tell you something no
yes I'll tell you something there is a
myth about all this stuff too because
yes we should try to be healthy on the
off chance that our bodies are those
bodies
tell you red meat diet rhetoric I'm
gonna [__] you
um Peterson when people be fat no he
wouldn't even having this discussion
he'd be like it's Michaela no she made
him all meat diet no they do the
carnivore diet yeah no I watch like two
I listen to the two podcasts about
carnivore diet
sounds fun I was scared of um vegetables
for a while I told you guys this yeah I
was like I listened to two podcasts
about it and I got I'm so easily
convinced some things I was like oh my
God they're like they're like why you
know vegetables would taste good if we
were supposed to eat them I was like oh
my God you're right they're poison it's
like they're the vegetables are poison
they don't want us to eat it so they're
putting poison out because they want to
survive and I'm like you're right you're
right and this was not a Michaela
Peterson uh it was like just some I
don't know
that is kind of interesting because
they're like what in your body but so
anyway so I'm like I completely am
buying this and I'm like I guess now my
only option is to go on the carnivore
diet even though I didn't want to I just
was like oh I'll listen to a thing about
it and I was like I don't want it but
then I was like I'm gonna die I'm
supposed to live to 120 they're taking
my life by eating these poisonous
vegetables and then I so then I started
like looking at different carnivore
people and being like okay and one there
was one thing about it that made me so
grossed out that I was like I'm just not
going to do it they said that your
muscle starts to feel jelly-ish and I
said I can't that I don't want why does
that happen I don't know why and I don't
I didn't read more into it but I was
looking for one thing to get out of it
but there was a while where Todd was
like you have to eat the vegetables he's
like how old are these people Todd was
forcing you to eat yourself Todd was
like what are they five years old they
don't want to eat their vegetables if
they don't taste good but that's
actually not even true because like
um that whole argument of like well if
we were supposed to eat it why does it
taste so bad babies eat straight up raw
like carrots all of this mushed Apple
everything without any complaint and
I've seen like my my my friends kids
when they're babies just grab it and
love it it's when we get a little bit
older that we have choices that are like
you know might be a little bit more
exciting for our palette that we're like
oh like vegetables is actually like not
as cool as this I don't like the taste
of vegetables me too I like it to a
tomato I enjoy but broccoli you know
there's certain ones that I can't have
anymore because it does cost like you
know painful gas [__] bleeding
painful gas yeah and I think that those
are there are inflammatory
um vegetables like I love onions can't
have them I I oh I can't have onions and
I really can't have onions I can't have
like I have to have minimal garlic it's
really sad bell peppers
it's not something it's something it's a
type of I don't know what it is but it
[__] me up I [__] blood like without
fail blood imagine life without onions
not to sound like the grossest girl in
the room but like I just explains a lot
of your smells like onions and garlic
are very important to the Jewish diet
like that's not I and I agree with that
I wish my body agreed with onions more
because I love onion flavor I love
garlic flavor I Garlic's okay with me
it's more like the night shades like I
mean I cannot if it's cooked onion I can
cut it raw onion which I love the taste
of it will ruin my life what about bell
peppers bell peppers hurt me but I will
like if I have um raw onions like I will
like
Elevate off I will fart myself off the
couch
well that's okay so I do allow myself
like like the you know the inflammatory
foods but I cannot have made plans that
night
a couple days off
I have acidic like your [__] when your
[__] is like and it burns and it burns
and and my pee Burns
where are you putting that
um me and Dave like we totally Bond over
we love garlic extra garlic I like
garlic but are you one of these people
like there's some people unto me it's
like I think my body would like shut
down and I would die I'd fall again some
people eat onions like apples no they
don't I swear to God yes no what are you
no they don't I think they did that
during the pandemic when they lost their
sense of smell no no a lot of people did
no
there's no way humans eat yes I guess
they do why
because they like it no this is like a
no I've seen people do it I was on a
pocketbook I was just eating they just
like them
um
I think it's good for you if you don't
have whatever art that is shocking but
what I was going to say before was there
are so many people that you see that
live very long and they eat Doritos they
eat pets it really is just like your how
your genes are gonna be affected by it
bro my grandma doesn't even eat food she
just drinks and smokes cigarettes and
she's interested
she sounds so hot
so it's like I look at that and I want
to go Goblin mode on your ground
I'm like your life choices can't really
always matter that much you just have to
choose like what am I going to be
stressed out if I'm dieting all the time
right yes stress on my body you can eat
all the perfect Foods exercise do
everything right but if you're living
like a really high stress life like your
telomeres will shorten and then there
you go it's like you're you're killing
yourself from the inside so what's the
point Whitney was talking about that I
remember especially in the beginning of
covet and she was so right she's like
everyone who's over stressing about it
like you're making yourself less healthy
like if you just sort of
you know I'm so glad you had that tape
because if she didn't let us over that
beautiful mansion I would have the
shittiest pin I know I'm so glad she was
like opened her not to Pivot into
anything super corny but this is super
corny but have you guys heard that there
are two new Love Languages no what are
they what mm-hmm are they is the love
language you hear new love line so the
five existence
so the five ones that we already know
are physical touch gift giving quality
time words of affirmation and
what's the fifth one acts of service
acts of service wait do we guess you
give us hints this is this is insane
breaking news but one of them is really
good and I think it's mine is it sex no
is it getting your butt okay so one of
them
shared new experiences shared news oh
that's so sweet but that I think last
time would have been like in quality
time that would have been yes it could
have just Fallen under quality but it's
specifically new experiences together
doing things for the first time together
that none of you had I that I love that
had done that done before the second one
is emotional security and this means
feeling safe feeling seen and feeling
listened to
these are the best this is like when the
M Ms added the blue flavor
the one the new thing [__] makes
everything better those are so good
those are so good you are a blue Eminem
she's obviously the green Eminem
great my favorite color the horny M M's
experiences is great that is really what
are some new experiences escape room
that is I've already been but or like
maybe going to a place
together yeah
um trying a new restaurant together
watching a new movie together like
something that
like a lot of times like in my
relationship it's like oh you got to
watch this movie yeah but you've already
seen it oh I don't care I'll watch it
again like that doesn't
um I had my friend Ed Bassmasters in
town who's like he's just like the
funniest he does all these pranks and
stuff he's from Philly and he does all
these different characters and we were
we went to The Comedy Store and he like
the clip will probably be up before this
comes out I'm sure but so he like comes
out like while I'm on stage he just
walks out in one of his characters like
from behind the the curtain like and
it's just so funny what did he do
nothing he just like walked up it was
just funny and weird and awkward but
it's really fun to do stuff with him
because he just is so he comes to La
every once in a while and he shoots he's
very good at like he collaborates with a
lot of people he's done a lot of stuff
with like Chelsea Lynn and Paige he
collaborates with a lot of people which
I admire a lot and he also is just like
all about being funny it's like what
could be the funniest thing and he goes
in and out of these characters I love
watching people you know working with
Sasha Baron Cohen too like when you see
how people kind of like maneuver in and
out of the character and stuff but it
was just it's been so fun
I just love little funny artist people
that sounds like like you're very
creatively energized by I am creatively
energized by it I love that feeling who
we had on tigerbelly on Monday was um
young gravy
I just met him I love him I love him he
said he would do this show by the way he
is such a bright beautiful thing I love
him so much I met him at vcon and I
didn't really he's from Minnesota is
that vagina con yeah what is vcon
garyvee has like a convention that I did
stand up at
um oh that's I did not know you did that
he's like a Minnesota boy so I just love
him but he's also like a MILF Hunter
like it's oh it's like a novelty but
like he really does like you know older
women didn't he date like Addison Ray's
that was funny when he showed up to a
thing with her that was great no but
they actually dated I love it they were
like yeah but
I really really like him yeah we should
have him on how was he on tigerbelly so
good so great he has such a fun energy I
think we'd have so much fun with him and
he's super open
yeah
is there a Vibe how old is it it's a
Vibe
um Bobby just totally like got in there
and said no no like he [__] blocked me
how old is he I'm sorry I'm sure Addison
27 cockroach that too 27 27 yeah
because I told him that you know this
tattoo right here this cover-up it's of
uh it's I the original tattoo underneath
it is matte it's uh the name Matt Matt
Rife from when you and Matt Rife dated
and so he was like oh
um
like can I claim like that that Matt was
actually like me and Bobby's like enough
Nelly [__] block Bobby you don't get to
[__] block also we do need to have Matt
Rafe on
did you know that he just broke the
record for selling out six Chicago
Theaters and six Radio City that's
awesome oh my God I know like that
little baby we need to have him on I
know I've known him I know yeah so cute
he's such a sweet kid like he's so sweet
the last time I saw him I could tell he
was like having a lot of obviously a lot
of fan interactions lately because like
I ran into him and when he said good
like we were in The Comedy Store parking
lot we give you prayer hands no he was
like he was like get home safe it was
like so it was always like this really
I I was supposed to go to Barry's boot
camp with Matt for like three years
I'll get there meet you there huh
well I think we should have a shared new
like exercise experience maybe yeah not
berries because we've all done berries
but it almost feels new at this point
so long that is true it's been a while I
already tried this but
um the class have you guys heard of it
oh yeah I tried it in New York they have
it here in Santa Monica but like that
was a really weird new workout
experience but I tried it already but I
do recommend it um I'm trying to think
of when I have is solid core or
something
I see that what about this isn't like
new to exercise but I don't know what
about aerial yoga I've never I've never
done that that would be crazy I've
obviously never done that because you're
too little to jump up on the thing I
have to hoist you up on nothing that's
so scary yeah but you would be so great
you're a dancer a dancer you're a dancer
maybe we get someone maybe we get a
private teacher film it
so that everyone else can enjoy yeah
that sounds good sounds fun or yeah I
have [__] shoulders but it's getting
down oh my God she's getting no this is
so annoying because she's like no we
can't film it I won't be perfect at it
but she will well no I can't even
lift up you can't live that's good you
and Bobby broke up
anymore David gel is the best joke is I
love reverse cowgirl because the girl
looks like she's getting up to run away
who said that oh no Bobby is a very like
Christian boy there's only two things we
can do because doggy is out unless he's
wearing these platform heels like he's
not which you would get him out Apple
box I know so we we so problem from we
know there's apple boxes on dirt sets
in my car I sit on one we were very
honest we did a very like honest
appraisal of our like height issues like
up front I'm like okay there's certain
things that we just cannot do so
um either Mish like super Christian or I
like Mish yeah Mish and then me on top
and it's always going to be me on top
because like everything sounds like an
Asian thing me on top
missed me on top have you okay I'm gonna
ask a really [__] up question oh my
God I can't wait to see what she thinks
is [__] up so you said like you know
Bobby's back in town like you've seen
him he's been to your place like
has there been any like like Vibes
sexual yeah
because I could really see that and I'm
just curious
what the [__] are you doing you're crazy
that is insane you're this is the most
master manipulator what are you trying
to do right now I'm not trying to do
anything I'm trying to get her back with
Bobby no I'm not I'm not I'm completely
objective I'm just I'm curious so
they're Vibes like there's cuddle vibes
okay like we watch movies together this
is breaking news is it I think there's
nothing breaking about it yeah the only
thing breaking is the internet is Reddit
no like we we watch you know we still
like lean on each other like if he's
like on the couch like laying down like
I'm still squish his belly like there's
still some squishy like we're really
like close but I don't think there's
necessarily like Vibes like oh this
could turn into something but when you
guys get into like serious relationships
are you gonna still be squishy with each
other they can't
I I don't I don't I don't know across
that bridge when we get there I don't
think they would want to I'm speaking
for her and him I'm their attorney I
hung out with my friend Nick again last
night he got a girlfriend
oh my spearfishing right by the way can
I just he's off the market he is he is
the king everything that he's done he's
working on Olivia Rodrigo's like third
it's third music video with her oh my
God he is so good he's he's a designer
designer is he in love
I don't know I think he's yeah I think
that
um I don't know why are Nicks hot though
yeah he's so handsome why are Nicks
generally like she's good like Nicholas
is a hot boy it smells the way you would
like you would like a little stinky but
in a way that you would like oh just a
slightly working yeah he's looking
working yeah I'm okay with that I like a
little Funk not scared of it he's so
good I'm wondering if he cares that I'm
talking about him like this but
I decided last night that I'm done with
caffeine because I was thinking about
wait hold on I was done I started again
obviously when I need after two days
after I get so tired it's just it's so
hard you know our lives like I've been
on the road like three days a month so
it's like I'm in different times I mean
three three weekends a month so like I'm
in different time zones all the time
it's like I'm so tired it's so hard to
not go to caffeine what's really [__]
is I thought you meant three days a
month because that's what I am and I'm
like yeah it is hard but it's nice I
have still the same amount of travel but
it's not as hard
um so I used to be like a six ventis a
day kind of girl like I slammed coffee I
couldn't do one thing if I didn't have a
big coffee in hand
um
my and the reason that I feel so much
better today is because okay maybe I
don't have that big burst of energy but
I at least my energy is consistent
throughout the day like I'm able to do
it just about everything until it's time
to go to bed right yeah you can exactly
even if it's a 20 minute nap but when
when I was drinking so much coffee it
was like I couldn't even think about
doing a single task without like a big
burst of caffeine it which still my
energy level was up down up down up down
that's exactly how I feel and I think
the nocturnal panic attacks that is like
it's like residual anxiety from
throughout the day of having this like
up and down and I'm just now looking
about like how can I maximize my time
how can I like use my time up because
there's a lot of projects that I'm
starting right now that I'm excited to
do they don't feel like I have to do
them for once in my life so I'm like all
right I want to actually Focus my time
on these things where do I waste my time
not only with the ups and downs and
being exhausted and not sleeping right
but I go to the coffee shop I talk to
people I use that as like a break to go
places I'm going so it's like I just
need to that's that's like a half an
hour are you saying you don't you're
back on coffee and you don't want to be
I stopped again today
I'm like getting I get off so hard on
talking about like you saying you drink
six venties I'm like because I for me it
is fully an addiction it's like fun it I
I'm like into all the Badness of it like
what were you doing before you quit Okay
I decided I hate coffee like I was like
for the past like before I quit drinking
coffee with the cluster headaches I was
drinking going getting
um
uh cold Brews and I would get nothing in
it just buy coffee I don't want any like
sweetener and things I don't like to
drink sugar like that so I'm just
getting coffee it sucks I'm forcing
myself to drink it I'm dehydrated my
jaw's tight it's just like I'm not
enjoying the experience of it so then
when I got the cluster headaches and I
couldn't drink coffee I was like okay
great this is like it's done it's over
then I was like I'm tired oh I don't
want coffee I'll get like a matcha and
then I was like oh but I really want
like that coffee feeling so I would get
like a double shot of espresso so it was
just done and then I get a matcha and
then like later in the day I'd have like
red bulls and stuff oh so you don't even
treat coffee like I used to treat it as
like a like I felt like a treat to me
yeah something that tasted good
something like a little snack I could
have like multiple times yes like a joy
yes oh yeah but if you if you're at that
point where you feel like you just have
to take it down so that you get that
right and it just wasn't and I don't
know how to like optimize that correctly
like I have a pitch which I have like I
think it was Michael pollen like someone
smart like a sciency person he was like
I know the perfect way to do coffee but
it's really hard and probably no one can
do it but it's you have a cup every
other day because then you like wean off
of it that second day so that then the
caffeine high hits harder every time you
have it right like because that is I bet
I bet of course when you took off from
having your cluster headaches of
caffeine and then you came back to it
was it just like sunshine and miracles
feeling I mean I was jacked I mean but
like a double espresso too it's like
it's fun to take a shot
like it's fun it's like the only shot I
can still take when you take a break
from caffeine and then go back to it it
is but it's overwhelmed it's like too
much because I'm not I don't manage
things well
I go crazy I go overboard fancy what do
we have here
well I was asking GPT about going
gobbling mode but I don't think
it knows oh so I think it's Goblin
that's the problem Oh god with me but
you know what we're bubbling
is like like
joking
yeah they both work they're both like
gobble a dick that's it right there
I shouldn't talk to Daddy
reaction as most people but um
what's gobbling mode
that I can show
[Laughter]
thank you so much for listening we love
you
and what a what a really on theme
episode today we've really made the most
of the robots
we talked all about it um so if you're
just waking up you know are you Pro your
pro AI
I have no strong I just don't understand
it enough to have a strong opinion of it
but like oh they're gonna get you then I
do feel like they understand you if it
kills us we're all in it together I'm
not gonna solve it I'm not gonna stress
about it like I just know what I what
happened to my life when I was so afraid
of code coming that like that didn't I
did not believe you remember when you
called me I was like shut up [__] so
annoying she's like seriously look at
Italy I'm like Italy you want to look at
Italy but like that didn't do anything
except [__] up my last few months before
you know the world shut down so I'm like
if AI is gonna take our oxygen or
whatever and kill us all like I'm not
gonna be researching about it and like
I'll be I'll be as of now I think it's
pretty cool I like I like to have I
think we have to evolve with the things
that are happening I'm not gonna be one
of those people that like fights what's
like happening but
um it could be cool could help us with
things yeah you could turn [__] wild but
you know TBD I guess but also if it
starts to kill us like I want to be the
first round of people that goes out I
don't want to be a Survivor like take me
out early okay and put that in the chat
it's listening don't worry Unfortunately
they bring Bobby with because
foreign
we'll see you next week bye
[Music]